oui
[Applaudissements]
oui oui
mais oui
mais à
et je kiffe ce jingle à ce que voulaient
que leurs maîtres
ah oui
oui ça sera temps d'aller donner
attendez on l'a on l'annoncent les gens
de la sacem ces deux là ça sonne c'est
pourquoi l'aide
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur jean pierre descombes je
voudrais dire encore merci jean pierre
d'être avec away fait hurler de rire la
semaine dernière et cette semaine je
vais participer au ni oui ni non car
vous verrez qui a perduré du tout c'est
la personne qui même le moi ici à bâle à
la mémoire merci ça fait plaisir
j'adore la mode sur des longs mois je
peux pas vous dire merci et ben écoute
heureusement que tu es là quoi on les
bat on va démarrer que jean-michel alors
lui faut bien écouter parce que parfois
tu as dit non ça c'était avant
d'accord ça c'est un bon bah c'est ce
qu'on va voir alors vous alors vous je
vous le dis c'est très spécial
si oui les non dits oui ni non vie
bafouille voilà les bafouilles away
normalement doit pas répéter plusieurs
fois le même mot également il faudra un
jour
attention c'est parti une minute on y va
c'est parti comme c'est parti
bonsoir comment ça va très très bien le
week-end s'est bien passé alors
admirablement qu'ils étaient chez vous
venez pas bougé j'ai un peu bouger comme
un petit peu un petit peu vous étiez
vous dans paris essentiellement au
théâtre pas du tout vous n'êtes pas
monter un jamais quel est votre
principal défaut j'étais en voyage
the stars vous bouger beaucoup je boite
e louis pas du tout sûr je ne lis jamais
te le dis jamais jamais jamais jamais ta
qualité première
la générosité dans quel domaine tu
aimerais tu plus doux et le foot non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
géraldine est ce que tu peux essayer non
aussi je te l'envoie là pas de norme au
passage ipd ouais ok je suis au bon
allez adorer c'est dur quand même temps
ça me parait n'ont pas duré deux minutes
attends pas si je me rate pas de pub pas
de sa célébration soit quoi excuse moi
sur la c'est correct al amoud dans
l'oeuf dans la face bon bah allez allez
c'est bon c'est simple donc ce week-end
tu étais sur un plan cul propos des
coûts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
touahri brésilien s'était c'est ce week
end là ce week end ça s'est bien passé
excellemment excellent à voir avec deux
ailes excellemment parfait à part ça ça
va toujours toujours tu m'entends dire
quand je parle je pensais bien je ne
suis pas sourd bien mais je m'approche
un petit peu 7le dans le mois un petit
peu de cette journée tu veux bien vous
donner des détails de ce plan cul bah tu
l'as dit non
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis entraîné toute la journée
jules adore jean pierre n'a pas perdu
juste vraiment d'améliorer la revanche
j'aurais branche vous la voulez tout
super boss vous voulez la non je suis
prêt croyons pas au top c'est parti donc
senna revanche en fait c'était bien
en revanche s'il se reprendre sa place
et du perroquet ah oui on ne doit pas
répéter ce que je dis d'accord d'aller
où il a tardé mais pour l'instant c'est
à dire ok bon contre on peut y aller on
y va il est un favori
la muscu la musculation dans une salle
et le sexe et peut pomper notre seul
souci j'avais trouvé la ceni j'ai trouvé
les succès d'un scénic est à trouver
inquiète la truite est rendue d'accord
tu m'auras pas j'aurais pas tu es sûre
pour le sexe non
[Applaudissements]
on se régale
ça fera un dernier en fin d'émission
junior tu fais le chasser à ça alors je
veux dire jamais notre attention à la
dame minerve comme ça je suis fan
non mais toi là mais toi là tu es très
bien très bien aujourd'hui qu'elle
m'allait vas-y baby schumi le cas de
rigolade attention c'est le match que
cela égale à 3 face à france 3 s'en
vient ça va peut-être jouer ce jeu j'ai
déjà joué le jeu et tu te sens bien
quand même
je me défends pas bien le public qui
joue eh bien je joue du piano chanson je
n'ai pas fini je joue du piano et de la
brique a le plaisir moi les paroles j'ai
fait à ne pas fait les paroles j'ai fait
de la musique la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
buquet respect de la vie de judas
occupez vous de juger jean pierre perez
et on les fait revenir dans le
sancerrois là dans cinq minutes parce
que je peux pas laisser souffler merci
email
pour pascal robert voiture avait encore
mises à pied tout ça est ce que tu veux
dans ma chronique
réputé pour me gillot tu peux aller
choper à la plus récente
[Applaudissements]